hey et welcome here is your first  exclusive look at this year's head of  household bedroom 2 what would look like  the backstage of any Broadway show this  would be like the Stars dressing room  we've got the makeup lights we've got a  headboard but I actually am told this  was a real theater marquee what is every  star get in her dressing room backstage  flowers break a leg your fabulous wigs  yes we all wear wigs back bed and today  that hasn't changed and this is the  upstairs lounge maich looked like the  iconic Brooklyn Bridge with the lights  and the way we strung the light this is  where house guests usually whisper hang  out they pretend like they're playing  chess oh they pretend like they're  playing pool but they're really like  conspiring about game play and how fact  that their house thinks this is where it  all happens  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]